قالت وزاره الخارجيه القطريه ان رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني ناقش في واشنطن يوم امس مع
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك سوليفان
ضروره ايجاد حل عادل للقضيه الفلسطينيه
وسبل خفض تصعيد في القطاع كما جرت مناقشه
ضروره استمرار دخول المساعدات بشكل مستدام
الى
غز وفي مقابله مع شبكه فوكس نيوز
الاخباريه الامريكيه قال رئيس الوزراء
وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني انه يجب التركيز على وضع حد
للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه واعاده
الاسرى الى عائلاتهم وايجاد طريقه لمنع
تكرار ما حدث في السابع من اكتوبر مره
اخرى واكد وزير الخارجيه القطري ان تحقيق
ذلك لن يتم الا عبر
المفاوضات اكت ما حدث في السابع من اكتوبر
والحرب التي تلته يجعلان الوضع ملتهبا في
المنطقه باكملها وهذا امر نحتاج الى
احتوائه علينا التركيز على هدفنا المتمثل
في وضع حد لهذه الحرب واعاده الرهائن الى
عائلاتهم وايجاد طريقه لمنع تكرار مثل هذا
الامر مره اخرى ولن يتم حل ذلك الا بالسبل
السياسيه على طاويله المفاوضات العمل
العسكري لن يحقق لنا النتيجه التي
نريدها قال رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطر الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
لشبكه الاذاعه الوطنيه العامه في الولايات
المتحده ان بيار قال ان الهدف هو انهاء
المحادثات في اقرب وقت واعاده الرهائن
ووضع حد للحرب في غس اضاف انه لا يمكن
ضمان سرعه تقدم مفاوضات الرهائن وان الامر
يعتمد على الجانبين واتمنى المسؤول القطري
ان يحدث اي امر يؤدي الى تقويد تلك الجهود
او يعرض العمليه للخطر من جهه اخرى رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري ان اي هجوم
على القوات الامريكيه قد يوسع نطاق الحرب